the disproportional reason so many
people in here will not win let's just
get right to the chase the
disproportionate reason that most people
in this room will not win is actually
not the hard work which is what I'm
going to talk about probably for the
next 45 minutes it's your lack of
patience for some unknown reason when
people go into ventures like this and
other things they somehow miraculously
think it's gonna happen in five minutes
that you're the one person in the world
whatever you guys call your big club and
put posters of each other upon you think
you're gonna be in that circle in five
minutes for some reason because you're
the most charismatic you've figured out
some weird system you've got it and the
lack of patience is what hurts so many
people from 22 to 30 years old for eight
years in my 20s I worked 15 hours a day
seven days a week in my dad's liquor
store today with all the things that
have happened to me I get emails on
Facebook from friends I went to high
school with often starting with Gary
you're so lucky
I reply to every single one of them all
of them with the reply of an opening
line first Jan great to see you again
you look great
kids super cute PS I am super not lucky
let me remind you Rick remember when we
graduated college and you went to the
Jersey Shore every weekend and hooked up
with chicks and drank beer I worked
[Music]
you
[Music]